طبعا هؤلاء الاطفال الذين تم لم شملهم مع
عائلاتهم اليوم جاء ذلك نتيجه شهور من
العمل الدؤوب من قبل الدبلوماسيين
القطريين مع شركائنا في روسيا واوكرانيا
بدا ذلك في الصيف الماضي مع زيارات معالي
رئيس مجس الوزراء وزير الخارجيه الى كل من
كيف وموسكو حيث تقدم الطلب
الاوكراني او تقدم الطرف الاوكراني بطلب
للوساطه في في هذا الشان وج معاليه الى
موسكو بهذا الطلب وقبل طبعا في لقائه مع
بوتن قبل بترحيب وبناء على ذلك تم تشكيل
مجموعه عمل من خلال مجموعه العمل هذه التي
تكونت من الاطراف الثلاثه تم تبادل
المعلومات والعمل حقيقه بشكل حثيث جدا
للوصول الى لم شمل هؤلاء الاطفال مع
عائلاتهم الامر الذي تم طبعا في السفاره
القطريه هذا اليوم وراينا جميعا الصور
المفرحه حقيقه بالنسبه ل جميع من عمل في
هذا الملف وهذه فرصه حقيقه ان نتوجه
بالشكر الى كل من الحكومه الروسيه
والاوكرانيه على دورها الكبير في في هذا
الامر وتسهيل وصول هى الاطفال الى ذويهم